If I have surgery to remove both breasts, cancer is ER positive. So this person is ER positive. Estrogen receptor positive breast cancer. They're going to have a double mastectomy.
Do I still need to take natural rheumatase inhibitor?
Um, the answer is yes. And you think, well, I'm having that cancer removed. So the cancer was in my breast.
Let's say, and I don't know, but let's pretend that person in a PET scan was only localized in the breast. There was no positive signs of the cancer beat anywhere else in the body, not the lymph nodes, nothing.
Um, so you're going to remove the cancer. So you're debulking the cancer. No, not debulking it. I'm removing it completely. Well, the thing is, is that long before you were ever diagnosed with cancer, you have circulated tumor cells.
And those are also ER positive, most likely. So, um, they're still going to be, um, rolled to having estrogen attached to the estrogen beta receptor and have it lock a poptosis.
Um, so you still want to do an aerobotase inhibitor. If you were going to an ecologist, and you're following your oncologist's recommendations, then they would be recommended you stay on their natural, they're not natural.
The aerobotase inhibitor medication. Um, and people will go, why do I need to do that when I have it by breast ribbons, same question, because you still have circulating two or cells elsewhere in the body just because it didn't show up on a PET scan.
What does that mean? I don't have cancer anywhere else. It means that you don't have cancer larger than three million cells large.
So if you have cancer that's 300,000 cells large, it's not going to show up on a PET scanner, CT scanner, MRI, you're not going to be palpating it, you're not going to know that it's going to mold.
You just have to assume that that possibility exists not to try to be negative, but you have to be, you know, um, you have to be a realist.
And so you still do the things that's like, okay, if I'm going to have my post breast ribbons, I have to keep using the right. Well, of course you do.
If I have to keep eating right, of course you do, but he'll get oncologists that say, no, you don't have to do that. Oh, you're, you're at a clean bill of health.
And then all of a sudden the cancer comes back with the vengeance sitting here. We'll never get back with the vengeance. It was never completely gone.
And you pretended it was so you have to continue treated it as it. So yes, you still have to take it.